-Maps on mobile devices
have changed the world
over the last few years.
They not only provide a
local map in your pocket,
but also a map of the entire
world, down to street level.
And even a 3D fly-around
of many major cities.
In the Maps for Android
Developers course,
created by Udacity
and Google, you'll
start by learning how to add
maps to your Android app,
and you'll progress to
using the street view
API to build a virtual hike all
the way down the Grand Canyon.
Learn about the camera and how
it's used to project a map.
You'll learn about zooming
to different locations
and changing the camera
tilt and direction.
You'll learn about
markers and how
you can place them on a map.
Take this course to
learn how to transport
your users from
wherever they are
to wherever they want to go.
For more information
visit udacity.com/google.